farmers have poured fertilizer and old
tires from their tractors at government
buildings in france's second city leon
to protest the removal of meat from
school canteen menus
the agricultural workers brought cows
and goats to set up many farms in
protest at the city mayor's move
authorities claim scrapping meat from
school meals will help in the fight
against coronavirus
the new health protocol calls for two
meter social distancing in school
canteens
a single meat-free menu will serve
students faster
and streamline meals many parents are
fuming at the move warning that families
from more deprived communities in
particular are going to suffer though
i think that unfortunately it's a very
political decision which could have been
made with more consultation
and in particular with the participation
of parents for some families it is the
only possibility to eat to have meat in
the diet
at least a few times a week children are
growing
and we're depriving them of dietary
diversity for me
it's a restriction on our freedoms i
don't understand how mps can intervene
in questions of diet
the way they do and if we have to
respect their ideology
they must respect ours so i'm absolutely
against it
poor families who relied on canteens on
schools to provide meat in meals to
children will now have no more
so we can say that the mayor of leon has
absolutely no solidarity with less
well-off residents with working-class
families
and that worries us farmers say the
decision is just the latest assault
though on their ability to earn a living
famine is again targeted by what a
minority of french people are saying
and unfortunately for us it's not a blow
in our heads
we're at the city hall now because they
can't impose their ideas by force in
particular banning meat in schools
supposedly because of coronavirus
you